[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google Cloud recently
announced the new PostgreSQL
interface for Cloud Spanner.
This combines the power
and reliability of Spanner
with the familiarity
of Postgres.
Postgres is a well-established,
open-source database
with a vibrant and
growing ecosystem
that many development
and ops teams are already
familiar with.
The Postgres interface
allows organizations
to take advantage of
Google's managed relational
database using standard tools
and skills from the Postgres
ecosystem.
The interface supports Spanner's
rich feature set, as well as
common Postgres data
types and SQL syntax.
In this video, I will
show you how easy
it is to set up a Spanner
database with the PostgreSQL
interface, then integrate that
into a Python application using
the open source
Spanner client library.
And finally, I'll use the
standard Postgres psql
command-line tool to
explore the database.
First, let's create a
new Spanner instance
using the Cloud Console.
I'm creating a small instance
for this test with Spanner's
granular instance sizing.
I can easily scale that up
later as needed without downtime
or rearchitecture.
A Spanner instance can
host multiple databases.
If you already have an
existing Spanner instance,
you will need to create a new
database with the Postgres
dialect support.
When I create a
database, I can choose
between Google Standard SQL
and PostgreSQL as the dialect.
I'll select the
PostgreSQL option.
Both dialects support the
same set of capabilities.
It's important to mention that
the Postgres interface does not
implement all of
PostgreSQL functionality.
Rather, it provides Postgres
syntax for existing Spanner
features to avoid having
to learn new semantics when
you begin using Spanner.
So next I will
create a users table.
I'll use Postgres
DDL and data types.
Because it's just Postgres,
this schema change
would run the same in any
other Postgres environment.
So this makes applications
written against the Postgre
interface more portable.
It's worth mentioning that you
can use the gcloud command line
tool to create the
database if you prefer.
Just make sure to specify the
--database-dialect option.
Leveraging one of the
supported Spanner drivers,
you can start
writing applications
against the database we
just created right away.
Besides the Spanner
client library,
no additional
software is needed.
For example, we have a
Python application here
that connects to our database
and leverages the PostgreSQL
interface.
I've downloaded the Spanner
Python client library
and installed it via pip
into my virtual environment.
In this simple application,
I import the library
and define the
instance and database.
Then I issue an insert
into our users table
using familiar Postgres syntax.
For instance, I'm not having to
specify a column list, like I
would with Spanner's dialect.
You'll also notice that I use
the Postgres NOW() function
to populate the
timestamp columns,
rather than the
CURRENT_TIMESTAMP() function
available in Spanner's
default SQL dialect.
I just showed how we could
use the native Spanner
driver to run Postgres syntax
SQL from a Python application.
But what about other tools, like
psql, that don't know anything
about Spanner?
For those, we provided
a proxy called PGAdapter
that translates the Postgres
wire protocol into Spanner's
own gRPC-based protocol.
To set it up, you will
need to authenticate
with the gloud command-line
tool to generate
the credentials required
to connect to your Spanner
instance.
Then download the
pgadapter.jar file and run it.
That's it.
With PGAdapter running,
the only thing left
is to connect with psql.
I can use psql syntax
to list out the tables.
Now I can create a unique index
on the email field in our Users
table, again leveraging
Postgres syntax.
Next, I want to query
the information schema.
You can see that the
Postgres data types
are displayed for the columns.
Initially, PGAdapter is only
provided for development
scenarios with
psql, but we'd like
to support a broader range
of Postgres tools eventually.
So that's how easy it
is to set up a Spanner
instance with the new
PostgreSQL interface
and get started using it in
your application and with psql.
If you want Google's highly
available and scalable managed
relational database and already
know Postgres' SQL syntax,
this is for you.
The PostgreSQL
interface for Spanner
is now available for preview.
You can sign up for the
preview by filling out
the form in the
description below.
Go ahead and try it
out and let us know
what you think in the comments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]